Dr. Zakia, following on from the first
episode we had on Zakat,
I'd like to ask you, if I may,
if a shopkeeper has a number of goods in
the shop, is zakat applicable on all of
the goods in the shop or just some of
them? Alhamdulillah.
As far as zakat on goods in the shop,
all the merchandise and goods for trade
and commerce
which are bought and sold, whether it be
property, land, whether it be
animals, foods, machinery, whether
stationary, with the food stuff,
anything, all of them are liable for
zakat. And
whatever goods that are there in a
grocery shop or whatever is there for
trade, there should be an inventory made
and all should be noted down. And once
in a year take the stock of all the
goods available whatever is there for
trade irrespective of what it is cars
vehicles whatever it is they should be
noted down and zakat should be paid at 2
and a half%.
Whatever is there in the shop the stock
as well as the profit was remaining at
the end of the year
that calculating on should be noted down
and zakat should be paid at 2.5%.
Except
the land
of the shop and the furniture and the
vehicle used for transport. These can be
exempted from zakat. Otherwise, all the
trading stock everything should be
calculated for zakat.